if there had been no Winston Churchill
I'm not certain America would be in its
preeminent position today Western
Churchill ought to be remembered because
in May 1940 when it would have been easy
to accept peace terms from Hitler he
stubbornly second no hi I'm Nick
Gillespie for recent TV today I'm
talking with Mike McMenamin the
co-author with Kurt Zoeller of becoming
Winston Churchill the untold story of
young Winston and his American mentor
who was Bourke Cockran and why was he
important the Winston Church was an
Irish American Democrat congressman
lawyer and orator he was acclaimed
during his lifetime roughly during the
the the last 10 years of the 19th
century first decade first two decades
in the twentieth century is America's
greatest orator I mean William Jennings
Bryan was inspired by Cochran William
Jennings Bryan wouldn't appear in the
same stage with Cochran because he
didn't like the competition Cochran was
a Tammany Democrat who never served more
than two terms in Congress at a time
because he couldn't be controlled by Tim
he was independently wealthy as a lawyer
and he was a big deal in New York he had
an estate in Long Island I mean he came
to America when he was only 18 by the
time he was 40 he was making a hundred
thousand a year as a lawyer that
translates today into 2.3 million a year
he had a home on Fifth Avenue he had a
300 acre estate on the Gold Coast in
Long Island what was his political
profile what were the basket of issues
that he cared about
he was a classical liberal he was a
close advisor to Grover Cleveland who
was perhaps the last classical liberal
Democrat to hold the
office he believed in free trade he
supported trade unions at a time when
the government was using the antitrust
laws to suppress unions he opposed the
death penalty was a strong supporter of
civil rights of civil liberties free
speech he was everything that was good
then about the Democratic Party let's
talk about Winston Churchill how did
Cochran create Winston Churchill
Churchill was only twenty years old when
he met Cochran who then was 40
Churchill's father had recently died
Churchill's father
Churchill loved his father wanted to
live up to his father's expectations but
his father's handling of Winston was
negative Winston could never do anything
good enough to please his father
Cochran came along met him it was
immediately impressed by him and instead
of tearing him down which is what
Winston's father did because Winston
wanted to go into politics he wanted to
follow his father but no one was telling
him he was good enough now Churchill had
a very strong ego he certainly thought
he was good enough but Cochran
recognized in Churchill the kind of
things that Churchill saw in himself and
some of their letters some of Cochran's
letters to Churchill show the important
role that Cochran had in invalidating
Churchill's career and he's telling
Churchill this when Churchill is only 21
and no other adults except perhaps his
mother are killing him this and young
people need a mentor who will validate
their dream you see ya kid you can do it
you've got it in you what are the
classical liberal strains that Cochran
implanted or pulled through Churchill it
starts with free trade because back then
in America at least big business
controlled the Republican Party
and they didn't want competition from
abroad Cochrane being a Democrat
representing lower-income people the
fact is that the protectionism costs the
lower-class more races the price of food
erases the price of everything and
Cochrane was such a magnetic
spellbinding speaker that he could
explain it in language people to
understand there's a great speech he
gave in the London stood to the Liberal
Party in 1903 where he's talking about
free trade protectionism and he said
look if if they're trying to sell you
stuff less than what you can buy it here
in this country what's the harm he said
if if someone is trying to take coins
out of my pocket I'm going to resist him
with everything I have on the other hand
if he keeps putting coins into my pocket
the only thing I'm going to do is urgent
to keep going if he shows signs of
becoming tired were there other issues
besides free trade that he pushed
Churchill into a classical liberal
position or framework well simply a
thought that government is is not the
source of wealth if if you read some of
Churchill's speeches back at that time
compare them to Congress you you can see
that they have a a similar style
although it's not as if he's aping
Cochran he has his own language the one
court I recall is from from Churchill
and he must have gotten this from
Cochran for a government to think it can
tax itself into prosperity it's like a
man standing in a bucket thinking he can
lift himself by the handles so he gave
Churchill a healthy distrust of
government and
and other organizations like the
organized church anyone that could hold
power over people and so when you read
their biographers describe the the core
of their beliefs
both Churchill and Cochran independently
you know the answer is Liberty that is
what drove both men and and you
shouldn't discount the power of
Churchill speeches throughout his life
he credited Cochran with teaching -
speak thank you Mike our guest today has
been my command a reason contributing
editor who's also the co-author with
Kurt Zola of the book becoming Winston
Churchill the untold story of young
Winston and his American mentor